what's trt uh testosterone replacement
therapy
so it's straight to it's not steroids
everyone's like oh steroids it's a
uh testosterone to get you to levels
where your body would normally be at
because it let's what let's normally be
at that age let's be clear
it is steroids it's just not steroid use
you're getting a doctor an
endocrinologist to analyze your profile
and then he or she will provide you with
the adequate amount of testosterone to
get you to a healthy level
when you say healthy level you could say
you know what i want to have the
testosterone
of a 35 year old yeah they could oh so
they could hit it by age or whatever
yeah i just went in for like my first
investment i'm not on trt but i
i started investigating the idea of
getting on it um
right before the lockdown and so i'm i'm
still not but um i i'm
you know but there's this weird kind of
stigma with trt
so let's say chin's deficient in vitamin
c
or chin's deficient in in some other
vitamin
you would take a supplement yes to get
your levels normally yes well
testosterone is no different especially
dudes after 30
who especially if you've had a
background in sports your testosterone
is going to go down i mean it goes down
so
you talk about depression energy levels
uh muscle mass
it affects your physical being your your
your mental being everything so
why wouldn't you take something to get
you up to normal levels what's the
difference then between
again i'm i have no idea you guys may
obviously this may be stupid questions
but what's
then one of the things like when i hear
about hgh and peptides do they do the
same thing as the tnt
hgh look testosterone is one sexual
hormone within
the male male and female body but
predominantly in the male body
um human growth hormone and igf-1
they're they're separate
igf-1 insulin growth factor so they both
kind of run in the same in the same
uh their brothers and um and you can
manipulate human growth hormone and
testosterone
uh simultaneously to help get you back
to a healthier more vibrant way
um there's also caviar about it i don't
mean to rep you a little caveat about
hgh though so
the one thing that's scary about hgh to
me which is one of the reasons
you know i don't i'm not opposed to it
but let's say you have a dormant
uh cell that's cancerous yeah well
hh doesn't pick and choose what it's
going to grow and multiply
uh so so so my family
and for me for example my family and i
like i've had a bunch of moles already
removed from my body right just so that
would be something that
i probably shouldn't come close to hgh
because no i don't think it's going to
[ __ ] with your moles well the mole is
cancerous
like right so you have that it's like a
melanoma it creates it recreates growth
of cells and i
i would listen to that's what i
obviously obviously talked to an
oncologist but things like um
there's been problems especially in the
world of bodybuilding stuff like yeah
with kidney tumors and and and stuff
stuff
power gut like when you notice
bodybuilders when they're they flex and
you're like god he's
jacked but there's like a guy yeah
that's a turtle shell
that's a because the hgh again it
doesn't pick and choose
just to grow the good stuff it's going
to grow your liver your kidney
there is there is something to that
though that that that comes with
equilibrium that comes with hgh abuse
that's why
if you look at like there's plenty of
pro bodybuilders standing on the mr
olympia stage the peak
that still have tight little ways some
of these guys are using they overdo it
for preposterous levels their heads grow
too and they yeah you see the guys with
the big with the big
heads and jaws and the big weird kind of
deformed face and
i will tell you you know for me as i've
gotten older the one thing i've learned
about like
i was always for years i was like why do
i'm in great shape but why does it feel
like i'm
blow i'm bloated all the time and what
if what i found for me anyways just me
it was a hundred percent there were
things that i was eating
that was causing inflammation in my
intestines in my gut
so it was pure inflammation it wasn't
gas because it never came out
i was causing swelling inside my body
right
and when i stopped eating those things
it
completely flattened out i didn't change
anything else
it just completely took away the bloat
100 there there's a lot to that and
i always am wary of like the holistic
hippie
stuff and they'll tell you like if you
eat you know dairy you're guaranteed
this is the level of inflammation
yes reality is it's not true every
human's so wildly different
but there's a lot to be said about the
fact that certain foods
are gonna [ __ ] with you and certain
foods aren't and and and inflammation
and bloating is a real thing
and that's why like i'm not a carnivore
guy
but i do see like the big value to this
meat only diet
is that that's the one thing that the
homo sapien doesn't seem to have any
bloating or inflammations with
and so if you can go maybe a couple
weeks like just resorting to eating
nothing but meat
it gives you a chance to kind of
understand what you are putting in your
body
when you start adding things back
because that's dr drew's jack does he
trt
super juicy he is jack he can't because
he has prostate he had prostate cancer
oh so he's just actually jack and he's
all he's always been jacked but
also dr drew does train like a maniac he
has a gym in his house and
i've pumped iron with him a couple of
times dr drew is a like
passionate meathead savage really loves
to just the smartest meat headlights
i love that man i i i would i
have done so much experimenting with
what i put in my body
like and how i i went pure i told you
this last time
i was on and uh and callum was here
where i just went
i went vegan for three months and i just
ate beans greens nuts and seeds
because i wanted to strip my body and
then put things back one at a time to
see how i felt
it was fascinating that some things that
i thought were good for me
didn't mix well with it wouldn't it
weren't good for me and i just was never
putting my finger on those things
but for me it's just like you said 100
when i read diet books and all this
stuff
it's such [ __ ] because all three of
our machines are different
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this wrote a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son